to go back then i think would be a rude
awakening for for a lot of people today
in terms of what you could or couldn't
do
because of cultural and social
enforcement so that's that's my big
concern today with things like critical
race theory black lives matter and
commercials
that it's not so much about what's legal
you're allowed to go and do things it's
about
someone will dig up a tweet from you
from 10 years ago and then you can never
get a job again you're basically being
ostracized
for something at the time was fine and
now isn't well that's cultural
enforcement imagine having such
magnificent technology where you can do
such a thing as tweet and then someone
else can dig up that tweet and you don't
need and nobody's forcing you to sign up
for twitter in the first place and
there's the the technology we're living
with is what they would have
called science fiction a very short time
ago let alone going back in the day so
and i'm not saying let's go back and
live like
washington and jefferson i'm saying we
need to uh
look at the ideas that they came up with
fine tune them
and expand them to everybody you know
include all races and
all all all 78 genders i'm saying
there's like 144
that i think no i mean they have and
anyone who identifies at any gender
obviously has the right to do that i
think we all can agree with that
um but um they don't have the right to
require somebody else to call to call
them anything or to treat them any
certain which is which is part of what
i'm saying about cultural enforcement so
look obviously but also like you can't
really speak about what's taking place
in the culture and
not acknowledge the fact that we have a
largely meddled with economy so we have
business and government
largely blended together regulation
and subsidies right so favors and
penalties
you got to divorce the two and that's
exactly uh what the founding fathers
should have done more explicitly they
did a pretty good job
implementing a separation of state from
economics not a perfect job but a pretty
good job
but they should have put it in writing
so in the c in the constitution it
should have said
separate church from state separate
economics from state wouldn't that be
one i don't think separation of church
estate is in the constitution though
wherever it is i think it was just like
an ideal of the founding fathers that
was enshrined in like their writings and
i don't know if it is maybe the
federalist papers or something i think
it is isn't it
well i guess the first amendment is what
you would say is kind of where we get
that right right right the right of the
individual to be
this is the place for the highest
cutting edge intellectuals on the
internet right now we got tim pool we
got me
we got this mother hey hey and it's a
dragon on the end
and producer lydia lydia yes
yeah so here here's what i mean by uh to
go back to cultural enforcement if we
want to take these good ideas from the
founding fathers
i completely agree with you i want those
to be put more in application today
have the individual the right anybody
who wants to identify as whatever they
want can
you can be respected and live their
lives but it's the authoritarianism
it's the if you don't say this you're
fired right we had an actor on the show
uh last week and he was saying like he
goes to these rehearsals and they're all
announcing their pronouns
and it's not it's not like there's a law
but you know what happens if you refuse
to do it
you don't get your job and you don't
work and then you may as well
find a different career one that's not
been infected by this cultural dogma
so if you want classical liberalism
you've got to contend with the fact that
you know politics is downstream from
culture we can get a bunch of great
politicians to talk about a bunch of
great ideas
but then if no one is willing to do
certain things because they're scared
their neighbors will yell at him it just
won't happen
yeah i mean look you know i said you
can't you can't look at the way
the world is going and people are having
their livelihoods destroyed and all
types of problems without
acknowledging the fact we have a
regulatory state and a largely
tampered with economy but i'll go
further and say you can't look at the
way people
behave and what they believe without
acknowledging the history of philosophy
so
the fact we have a world where so many
people uh
think they can invent their own gender
or that we live in a world where
people think that you know calling for
accomplices
and basically overthrowing civil order
is
acceptable and that is conducive to life
on earth
it speaks to philosophical development
so i will offer you the following after
the founding fathers and the men of the
age of reason and maybe some women as
well i don't know
um sort of came up with their
innovations in philosophy and they
discovered that
the nature of man calls for his rights
to be protected
by a government with a monopoly on force
and i think john locke
john d have you even read locke you know
played a large role in
in providing people like thomas payne
with
uh those ideas but after america was
established
the um the intellectuals of the
generations after them
uh they put all of their effort into
basically reversing
what the founders had implemented
intellectually so
the uh what they call the um
before the progressives uh the the uh
pragmatists
pragmatism is the american philosophy
not the founders philosophy but like the
post-founding
american philosophy you go to any public
school you go to any
house of learning since you know
sometime in the 19th century and onward
pragmatism was like the uh was the
american
philosophy which it was influenced by
the germans it was influenced by hegel
um and other and kant and other
philosophers who rejected
certainty they said look all you know is
you can't be certain i mean they said a
lot of other things too but
once that was in place one's
intellectual said that the individual
cannot
look at the world independently observe
it independently
and be rational about it and make
indepen independently rational
decisions and live and should be
protected
in doing so that his rights right to do
so should be protected
once they were rejecting that type of
independence
and the rejected reason in essence the
era
of the founders was over the era of the
age of reason
was over and now you had educators
basically training students
to be well socialized young boys and
girls they were teaching them to be
sheep
they were teaching them not to think and
with each generation we've seen it get
worse we've seen people get
less independent less rational we've
seen random acts of violence you know
in the 19th century there would be
someone who would shoot up people
randomly and it was shocking but it
happened
obviously jumped forward to modern times
and before this lockdown it was like
every two weeks uh
some potentially worse now yeah but i
mean when you reject reason
at the highest levels of the
intellectual world then what do you
expect kids to be taught
in you know elementary school think
about that the idea of
you know divine providence or whatever
that just trust
me the lord wills that i be king or
whatever you got to take away
reason from an individual if you want to
establish a system like that
for the longest time people didn't
reason it just was
and so long as you had the zealotry the
king could maintain power
y'all i'm gonna make i'm gonna make a
statement that's gonna get me in trouble
but i'm gonna say it anywhere we go
donald trump's presidency is in is in a
certain way
similar to like the way you're
describing the american revolution and
the founding fathers
you're angry now see hold on let me let
me tell you why all right i'm not
i'm not saying because i i think but
i'll get the idea i'm not saying because
trump was right i'm not saying because
trump was good i'm saying
because it was basically an affront to
the established order
that donald trump was not supposed to
win whatever it is he was doing was was
offensive to those in power
and so they very much did not like him
and said this can't happen again
i look back at the founding fathers and
you have this point where there was a
deviation away
from the crown and the absolute
authority of those who are you know
willed to be kings
and like you mentioned all of a sudden
generation after generation
they've stripped away reason and taught
children to be better and better sheep
till now here we are well i mean uh i
i think a lot of people who like trump
um
that are whom are not bad people would
probably say they were drawn to him for
reasons that you described because they
see a sort of push back against
authority authority or being told
what to do and they see him as sort of
this uh kind of
independent guy that doesn't let the
media or anyone tell him what to do
i get that but left um sort of
unchecked like kind of left without um
without any correction
what trump i think represents is just
this dispensing with any sort of
rational method
trump says what passes through his head
and that becomes
so-called reality and his fans love it
they're willing to die on that hill
um quite literally i think so a decent
amount of them i would say
you know look out of 74.2 million people
it was a much smaller fight i'm not
talking about
about anyone who voted for him because a
lot of people voted for trump as the
lesser of two evils or even because they
like some things about him but i mean
i'm talking about
what trump represents the way he's
influenced the republican party the way
he's influenced the way people go about
politics
um i think he definitely represents a
serious development for the worst but i
i get where you're coming from when you
say that
kind of emotionally he he speaks to
people sen sort of
like the ghost of the founding fathers
in i don't even mean that though no
i'm just saying like you have an
established order you have the other
democratic and republican establishment
and then all of a sudden trump comes
along and he's a bull just stamping
stampeding through and kind of just
knocking over their stuff i'm not saying
there's an equivalence in his philosophy
i'm saying that
you have you have kings you have
colonization you have war you have
monarchs autocrats
and here come the founding fathers
saying screw you what are you gonna do
about it
physically fought remember the founding
fathers were intellectuals and when they
weren't
killing the british they were taking a
lot of time
to make sure they got it right and they
had beliefs about the nature of man
and they were intellectuals and they
were really the one time in history that
intellectuals were also blowing heads
off but then
carefully crafting out a system of
government so i could basically flip
that and say the way trump behaves the
way he's willing to basically smash the
system reminds me of some
attilas in history some genghis khan
sure so
i mean by the way by the way kings kings
are not a natural fact of history like
uh kings and king the rule of kings did
not just
evolve like uh like the chimpanzee the
the king there was a time when there was
like let's say democracy in greece
far from perfect but much better than
you know just the king and the pope
right telling peasants how to live uh
there was wrong
there was rome which was you know also a
senate type of
system there was there were um ancient
sort of ages of reason where
they where they highly embraced reason
and they really wanted to get it right
and
so how did we go from that to the dark
age which very much exists it seems like
i think we're getting into that
it's possible i think it was the
rejection of reason which is why you get
brutes in charge
but real quick sorry do you think we're
heading into another dark age
if we uh on the route we're going
absolutely i'm sad to say i mean
listen i can't predict something like
that like let's say it's possible that
authoritarianism is on the rise
but let's say technology is just
developing so fast and people love it so
much that the authoritarians don't want
to take that away from people
like there's a there's a number of um
outcomes that where this can take us
that
i cannot predict i can't just
rationalistically say up
like all the uh all the things add up
like it all adds up we're going to have
um authoritarianism i can't predict that
but
the way we're going the way that reason
is being rejected the way that brute
force is being celebrated and we're
seeing brute force
a lot and so to have um somebody like
trump
in such a prominent place in society i
think
sadly does not say something positive
about where we're heading i like how
many nods i've been getting from you you
know i uh
i'm happy i feel i feel comfortable i'm
i'm happy to be here
get your ideas and your thoughts you
know what i mean i'll give you mine but
i will clarify too i'm not saying trump
is like the founding fathers
we can argue that there was an
aberration in the established order
where the founding fathers pushed us
heavily towards individualism and
freedom
and then with trump it was a rejection
of establishment they're not the same
thing
right so the point i was making more so
was that
the powers that be were outraged and
what i see is
with trump there was this this concerted
effort to fortify the election as time
magazine called it
because they did not want trump to to
you know
become president again or to get
reelected with the founding fathers
i absolutely believe you know what you
were saying is true there's there's a
lot of people
probably just because the system is
exploitable when you when you have
freedom it's very difficult to maintain
because
cheaters can cheat it's not true you
don't think so then how did it have they
done it
have they done what over time our system
has been exploited to push for the
lowest common denominator
our school systems are are making you
know our youth
institutionalized and incapable and now
we end up with a generation
of millennials saddled with massive debt
for degrees they can't use
and what skills have they earned from
spending all this money and just
being extracted essentially by sal you
know what would it say freddie mac and
sally mayor's name of the company
or these these these big loans ready may
or sally
i don't know the companies are i think
this is your place for mortgage uh info
that's right you got all the news no i
just mean like listen i mean to go from
the founding fathers
freedom to now have people demanding
communism
well not only are they demanding calm i
don't even know how much
people are demanding communism i think
people like let's say on the far left
are demanding some type something even
uglier than communism like some kind of
cambodian egalitarianism where everyone
with any level of privilege is shaved
down
that's a scary thing listen i can i can
sit here and throw red meat all day to
people on the ride and say these
leftists are as bad as you think but
but we're not only seeing calls for that
we're seeing calls for authoritarianism
we want people want donald trump to rule
and they want the next guy josh hawley
or somebody worse than him to be
like a populist loudmouth piece of trash
who does not care about principles so
how did we go from the founding fathers
to this basically it was the dispensing
of reason so the founding fathers did
not emerge in a vacuum they were
they were part of a tradition of the
development of the of philosophy
after them like i said the um the
utilitarians the um
the pragmatists came along what did the
pragmatists say they said you can't
really
live by principles right principles are
too um they're too constricting and you
know
you don't really know if they're gonna
work so what do you do just act just act
and see if it worked
and so how do you know how to act right
just well you can't use
uh principles right so just whatever you
feel do what you feel bro
that is unfortunately become the
american way thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time